[Music]
Tyra Banks is keeping it real revealing
she's gone under the knife in a new
excerpt from her book co-written with
her mother perfect is boring obtained by
people the supermodel admits she got a
nose job early on in her career tacking
on some cosmetic work to a sinus surgery
quote I admit it
fake hair and I did my nose I feel I
have a responsibility to tell the truth
you just do you darling
the 44 year old also opened up about the
challenges of being a body positive role
model I used to feel like my body was
not mine
I've been too thin or too big and I used
to feel like I was betraying people if I
lost weight kiss my I didn't realize
when I told the world to kiss my fat ass
that it was going to be the slap on the
butt heard around the world now Banks
says she's shed some lbs weighing in at
159 pounds quote I lost 30 pounds but I
don't feel like I'm betraying people
I've still got ass I've still got boobs
it's about getting your shape and shape
and finding your health regimen that's
gonna work for you
[Music]